damn hey what's up hey um
so i come from a muslim family and
you know i'm an adult and i do my own
thing i did outside my religion whatever
um but like having that conversation
with my partner
like is very difficult to have so why my
parents might not be
you know the concept of dating is not
really a thing
so as like coming from the male's
perspective like what is
that i guess what is that like
how does that how do i reciprocate or
try to understand their feelings more
is my question well i mean you're the
one who's coming from an extreme
environment so
at the end of the day it's like you're
the one who seeped into a world that's
very different than what most people in
north america would live
so you got to be the one who understands
that and is able to relay that to the
other person just a little bit
more information she does see them
getting like married in the future
that is something that they're working
towards they've been together for a few
years she hasn't told her parents
and she's you know he's not sure and
here's the thing
a lot of people deal with this issue
being with a partner who's from a
different religion having parents who
may not accept that
and and how do you manage that it's not
permitted in my religion to
live no i i'm well aware but you know at
least if you marry the person then it
makes it a little bit more palatable
yeah
but at the end of the day that
difference in culture and the difference
in religion is always going to be a
problem
you need to i think the moment you get
engaged to that man you need to tell
them
and you also need to prepare for you
know whatever is going to come from them
afterwards
uh if you want to be with this person
and you know that that matters and
and they're also committed then uh yeah
that's the only option that you really
have
but be prepared be prepared for that
whole conversation be prepared for them
to be very negative about it
and also be prepared for them to not
talk to you for some time
yeah because the thing is that since
they're quite old i'm like is it
really worth going through all of that
for them since they're
god damn they're good
[Music]
no but wait wait wait the thing is it's
not like it's not coming from a
place of um
do you have any brothers and sisters
yeah what do
do they know no are you gonna wait for
them to die too
no actually i don't really care if my
brothers and sisters
it's your parents really it's mostly my
parents like yeah my siblings i don't
really care if they know
it really comes down to this this is how
i am i i can't be bothered to live a lie
it's just not in me i don't care if it's
my parents i don't care if it's my
girlfriend i don't care if it's my best
friends
i just can't be bothered to live a lie
it's not my step you have to ask
yourself do you want to live a life with
some measure of integrity or do you want
to go online to your parents about who
you are forever
do you want them dying not knowing who
you're going to marry do you want them
dying not knowing who you actually are
even if it upsets them at all this point
it's like you don't have a real
relationship with your parents because
you've been lying to them for most your
life do you not recognize that
i'm sorry for interrupting you you know
i know it's not
um it's not the most common way of
thinking but
the thing is that i do not choose my
parents so
i do not necessarily choose to have the
most
authentic relationship with them since i
do not choose them i don't necessarily
you know you don't necessarily get along
you choose your friends so you choose to
get along with the friends that you have
but
you don't necessarily choose to get
along with the parents that you have so
you have to deal
with what you're born with basically
your parents so
you what i'm trying to say is that
it's not i don't necessarily think i
think that having the
most truthful relationship with your
friends and
husband wife whatever it's necessary but
you know your parents i don't
necessarily
agree that it's the that's up to you
that
that could be up to you if you don't
value having a real relationship with
your parents and that's that's
your choice and at that point i would
tell you to keep on lying then
you know like if you don't think it's
important to be honest to your parents
or to those who are close to you then
that's your choice and i respect that
um for me it's a different it's a
different thing so it's just a matter of
like what you value and
if you justify i get it i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna look at you like what do
you
you know for me it was important to have
an honest relationship with my mom and i
think i'm grateful for it because like
my relationship with her before was
trash
but if you don't care that much then
that's fine then just keep doing what
you're doing and don't tell them
so i want to get your thoughts preached
i'm going to teach you a word in in
creole it's called
that's me i straight don't give a [ __ ] i
do not
give a rat's ass if i'm if i decide to
marry
that person my parents can't nope you
can't say [ __ ]
that's me that's my territory and my
parents are super religious because i
i could tell them
that's what they said the marriage that
means the woman is going to leave her
nest and the man is going to leave a
mess
at her nest and they're going to rejoice
together and they're gonna form
one that's my one that's me me and her
that's my family now okay once i'm with
her
that's what i'm trying to build and and
you don't get to comment on anything
i got this you been commenting all of my
life
cool i got this i don't i don't yeah but
i really shush
how about forgot about food which means
it's none of your business
none of your business i'll be a creative
man of your
freaking business as a matter of fact
yeah about food
i do understand that for some people
their parents acceptance and all this
stuff matters a lot more it's harder to
just have preacher's attitude which
you know i'm i'm a preacher's camp like
my mom can't tell me nothing even though
i respect her and i revere her
at the other day it's my life i'm an
adult i'm gonna raise these kids
they're going to be my offspring's going
to be my partner i have to live with
them
so my acceptance matters more than
theirs of course
you know in most cases having your
parents acceptance is a wonderful thing
but you can't live on that basis alone
that can't be the
the defining factor now if you live in
their home
you need to move out because if you live
under someone else's roof
you have to play by their rules that's
how it be so if you're talking about i
want to do with this i don't do that but
they still paying your bills
well you don't you haven't earned the
right to demand those rights
right because you haven't you haven't
acted like an independent adult yet
you're still dependent on them so how
are you going to say i'm going to make
my choice it's my decision
while still being under the roof that
doesn't make sense boom now if you've
moved out
and you still are a little apprehensive
about telling your parents about who
your partner is i recommend waiting
until you guys are
are engaged and at this point you brush
the topic because you don't want to hide
it from them from
ever even if it makes them uncomfortable
you need to have that discussion
now if you come from that background
right that kind of uh
you know non-secular very religious
background and you're dating somebody in
the western world who's from a different
religion or not or more secular than you
it is your responsibility as someone who
comes from a different environment to
explain that to them and it's their
responsibility to be open and to try to
understand your different
reality right because you're the one
who's coming from something that's very
different
if i came back from war and i have ptsd
i wouldn't expect everyone back home to
understand what that means i have to
have a certain level of patience
and communication for them to get what i
went through
kind of thing does that make sense so so
i would tell you guys if you're dealing
with this and you you guys
got this huge difference you one have to
choose what's more important
getting your family's approval or
choosing a partner that you love you
know and if
getting your family's approval is more
important then dump them i don't
recommend living that way but if that's
how you want to live that's your choice
but if you care more about your partner
then you have to prioritize that
because at the end of the day your
parents are not going to be the one
married to that person it's going to be
you got to be in line with your star
player and ask you
that's right make that three point yeah
but again
only introduce that person to your
parents when you're sure
all right a lot of people out here
willing to be like oh this is my
boyfriend three weeks later they're done
don't do that that's a bad look if
you're gonna do the haram at least do it
for a good cause
well to some people no if you cover
muslim family and you
not talk about him okay i'm talking
about the people that don't know the
concept of haram oh yeah yeah but you
don't need to know the sin to know
you're
to to be engaging in one oh you know
what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah
there's like a there's a whole bunch of
apostates who are going to hell even
though they don't know it yeah yeah they
know it no
a bunch of non-believers yeah they're
going there's no hell i'm not getting
into this discussion but anyways so
that's my thoughts on that um if you're
dealing with this situation and you feel
like
there's more to this discussion by all
means leave in the comments below tell
us why your situation may be different
maybe we'll do a live in collins show
where all the infidels can all call in
and let us know what their struggle is
in regards to dating people from
different cultures and how it's been a
problem all the
haram yeah we want haram to just jump in
so if you guys want we're going to do a
live and call in show on sunday so if
you guys want to come in with some of
your problems all the harams let's go
let's get it bring the harams
all right bring your arms to me okay all
right cheers